(upbeat music)
(oil sizzling)
Here's a quick tip from someone we love.
Hi Drew, I'm Eugene.
You might know me as @the_eugefood.
I'm gonna show you the best way to reheat pizza, ha ha.
Get a pen, nonstick, doesn't matter.
You're gonna put your pizza into the pan cold.
We want this to come up to heat slowly.
Cover it with a lid.
Tin foil works too.
Let's be serious, are you just really gonna have one slice?
(chuckling) You're gonna get a tray, parchment paper,
pizza slices down like this.
Cover it with tin foil.
Your oven rack to the lowest rack.
Oven at 275.
(knife scraping)
Ooh, one of the oven slices.
Oh, listen.
(pizza crunching)
(humming happily)
Oh, so good!
(oil sizzling)
If you're gonna buy one piece of equipment for baking,
I say it's the scale.
It's all about consistency,
and weighing your ingredients makes all the difference.
If you want your batches to be the same
over and over and over again, use a kitchen scale.
Measuring flour in a measuring cup
can weigh different things every time
depending on how you do it.
If you scoop and sweep versus spoon and sweep,
it's gonna be a different amount of flour each time,
whereas when you weigh one pound of flour,
it's always gonna be one pound of flour.
If you do use measuring cups,
make sure when you're measuring your flour,
you'll put your flour in, sweep it level.
The same is true for measuring spoons.
You don't wanna dip it in there and have it heaping over.
You wanna level it off.
So these are the essentials
for measuring your dry ingredients.
(oil sizzling)
You can grow mint in the ground,
but this is where we have our disclaimer for mint.
Mint is a very aggressively growing plant.
That means that where you plant mint,
it will expand and it will pop up all over your garden.
So my tip for you in growing mint
is to either grow it in a pot or grow it in a raised bed.
If you don't want to dedicate a whole raised bed to mint,
you can actually bury a pot in the soil,
and that will help keep mint in this area.
We're gonna take your pot
and your pot can be as big as you want.
If you want a bigger section of mint,
if it's at soil level,
those runners would expand right across the soil.
So you wanna leave it high up, keeping your mint in check
if you don't want it to take over.
I live for tips.
(upbeat music)